you were talking about bombing always
get Comics to share their like worst
bomb like getting booed or something
thrown at them booing um bombing happens
like a lot in the beginning of your
career because
you don't know how to use all your
weapons interesting like you're a Jedi
but you know you don't know how to how
to swing your lightsaber how to work
your mind how to pick up [__] that stuff
you learn on the way
like I still bomb
but it's not a it's not like a bomb
physically where everybody goes man you
know [__] bomb
but I know I'm bombing inside I feel it
if I have to go to my a joke that I did
on my first special I'm bombing
yes
like last night yeah I don't know what I
started off with because I have a set
that I'm doing on Netflix in October
and I already know it by memory I know
how to begin with it I know how to
whatever right but I saw like the crowd
not into that [__]
and I felt like a hack doing it because
I already know these drugs but they were
getting laughs but then I switched back
to my other stuff but the real bombing
I've had where
it was ugly was it that place while
coyotes okay and I was bombing bro like
I had my notes and then um
that guy Willie barcela he was like a
bully you know like a comedy bully like
you know I guess you meet him everywhere
you go
like it's the kind of guy that of Europe
on stage and then when you get off he
sees your set list he rips get rid of
these jokes dog but it's true you get
rid of them you know they suck
but anyway so I'm bombing bro like like
I could feel it though so my back's
sweating like it was already sweating
and my five minutes turned into it felt
like an hour
you know I went through 20 minutes of
material in two minutes yeah I've been
there for sure my mouth gets dry bro
and um I'm bombing
and I'm bombing I don't know how to get
off that's the problem with bombing you
don't know how to get off and Willie
Barcena goes up there like he's my dad
and he hugs me on the shoulder and he he
goes he did like hand me the mic bro
so I give the microphone and he walks me
like off the stage like hugging me
across dying I'm embarrassed her it
hurts bro every step hurts
I heard you bro and I go up there he has
sweat on his arm yeah yeah he goes up
there give it up for Phillip give it up
for Felipe man you tried
he goes he tried man
that's all you could say he tried but he
failed
he went back for failing people
he bombed up here man I mean
nothing worked he was getting laughs
making fun of me and um and he was
getting big laughs I was getting angry I
should [__] this fool up right but he
was saying man he's like he's Mexican
man you people are Mexican you show him
no love you
that's what a problem man we never stick
together
you should actually laugh even if he
said knock knock jokes
ran across laughing right
and I learned from that message I didn't
learn that bombing right okay it was
stupid you know I should have learned
from that Bobby
but I just heard so much
and um
I don't know if you guys ever bomb Obama
could last three days oh if I mean the
last you go up again and if you bomb
again you might quit yeah yeah I was
just about to say that it lasts until
the next show and hopefully you can
rebound
I bomb on chocolate Sunday
at the Laugh Factory oh I've done that
yeah bomb hard we haven't bombed there
but I've done the show yeah
and uh what's the name um KT um what's
his name TK Kirkland t to the
[__] clerking on here yeah he's
a fool
he walks his he had a homeboy with him
right and a homeboy like an old comic
not even a comic which made it worse see
what happened Young Brother
you're up there too long
and I'm like I probably got 10 minutes
I didn't run the light afterwards it
bombed me to run your light oh dude
you're like this will get them you just
keep pulling them
uh so um he goes he was just up there
too long and then TK um Kirkland
told me you're funny
but you're gonna know your audience or
whatever right she said something like a
a I hate you he said a little bit of
Lobby podcast a little advice but I
forgot what he said but
he ended up being a good guy because
later on in the future he got me on a on
two shows where I got paid he got me on
a Nick Kevin Hart show he was hosting he
got me another show that um JB smooth
will hosting so he's a good guy I mean
he knows so he got me
but I bombed so hard
I had to redeem myself I said I can't
walk around with his egg in my face
so I go I I looked around I said bro
where's the next Urban show like
tomorrow he goes oh scruncho he has that
show at the Hollywood Park Casino
although I'm going there what time of
the show he was nine
but they don't start that [__] until 10.
of course I'll get there at nine all
right and I'll wait till everybody gets
in
so as soon as I get there the all-neuri
bomb
I really all need like Bob
so
Felipe who had a rough night last night
yeah I did and then he go all right so
did that show
bounce back and then I'm in a community
named Eric Blake
so I did the same jokes I did it I did
on Sunday but I slowed it down you know
I wasn't nervous I wasn't nervous and I
killed and then um a lot of the urban
Comics there gave me like a lot of
advice
I think Eric Blake and
scruncher told me that um and Eric Blake
he said listen man when you do an urban
audience
if you have a long story
try to say something silly on the way to
the story because they [__] lose
your ass
so I used to have a joke where I say
that I'm I'm sneaking this girl into my
house to have sex with her in my my
bedroom or my parents are at home
everybody's home and my brother's
sleeping in the top bunk bed
so man you gotta do the whole story bro
so I went up on stage I sit like this so
I'm sticking it to my mouth also I told
this girl walk over my dad
so I'd walk over my dad so I had a
little tags along the way to walk right
right right right yeah then I threw in I
started making love to like a prison
inmate
I added that I covered her mouth kept
her mouth shut the [__] up
so that that's what I learned details
but that nothing you know that that I
bombed there but I bombed the hardest
problem in Tacoma Washington because I
was a headliner and
um it was a bad bad deal
um
it was um
it was two shows I did a story a first
show I'll put together 700 okay for two
nighters One Night in Hawaii and one
night to coma
so they they flew they got me a plane
ticket and I flew out to Hawaii
and the night before so the night before
I got to see Hawaii for the first time I
met some Asian women they were cute I
took a photo with them I never been to
Hawaii I ate good I went to go to the
show bro it was like no lie bro
17 people there and I played was like
200.
and the promoter was sitting in the
front with a broken leg
so every child every time I worked
General joke I would look at it going
[Laughter]
I did the whole 45 bro no laughs
then I went to my room
I want to kill myself
so the next day
I'm waiting for for them to take me to
the airport
and um
the team they take me to the airport
late because they were smoking weed and
about a small weed I wasn't smoking weed
back then so I missed my flight Hawaii
flight oh I talked to that and then um I
talked to the promoter here man you're
home you dropped me off too late
you know I'm with my flight
you go wow man talk to them and tell
them your mom is dying telling me
getting married lie to them like the
promoter saying them
so I use I use the money
that they gave me have to buy another
ticket
to get to um
I think California at least
so I come from California I made to
California then I used 200 of my money
to get to Tacoma and if they were going
to reimburse me in Tacoma
so when I get to Tacoma
um I guess it's tradition I guess
his mother invited me to eat I never
been to know
um Urban Home you know African-American
house
so I'm with my hat I sit down
she goes oh you're gonna say hi to
nobody
yeah
I would never use so I sat down she goes
she go we take hats off in this house so
I took my hat off
and they made me some fried chicken and
macaroni and cheese chicken was
delicious the macaroni and cheese was
like the last part so I thought at the
mold of the pan on it
you know what I'm talking about right
yeah my piece was round oh yeah the
crust
so
I I there was a casino like nearby where
I was staying
almost like across the street so I went
over there and started gambling playing
Blackjack and I won like 980 bucks
and they picked up to a show I went to
the show
let me tell you something
for you anybody out there that's a
headliner or you're going to headline a
show or somebody calls you up
and to ask you I want you to headline my
room
before you even agree to the headlining
spot you asked him
how many comedians are gonna go up
before me
who are kind of ring and opener
um who else is going to go up what is
the show going to be like am I going to
be one comedian or a host and I go up so
I just said yes you know I said yes I
never I didn't ask none of the questions
was this before last Comic stand yeah
okay so I'm at the Tacoma Washington and
um
the whole world goes up before me
they bring up the rapper
the chef of the place goes up and tell
and shows the plate of the specials
like he's like this
some dumb whack-ass [__] does a Def Jam
rap that sucks I hate poetry first of
all I like poetry red I like to read it
I don't like to be read by people with
attitude you know
[Laughter]
so um
so this comedian goes up bombs bro a
state of comedian kills
but this guy one of those guys that has
like a funny he's um Tacoma 20.
right his [__] with only fun into coma I
swear to God but all his references was
killing like y'all remember Junior from
the barbershop
ah
remember when you broke his leg
they were running around a room laughing
and then and then The Barber of Barbara
was there bro oh so everybody's laughing
at him giving them high fives
so after that Thunder bro
I go up to try to do hour
they're like you
or Felipe bro you couldn't hear a taco
drop
you could hear a taco Grudge and I go up
there bro and
I say a joke
and um
some guys heckling me
but then he goes up on stage and we're
having a rose battle on stage bro
right
and I said and I looked and I looked at
him and the audience Chris Rock was
right
there's black people
and then there's all you guys
the crowd exploded bro oh they liked it
they liked it oh they laughed oh my
God and I said thank you good night
after that it could have gone either way
there yeah I said thank you good night
did you do the full hour [__] no okay
because they were heckling and yelling
uh all rude and the guy wouldn't get up
on stage
and um I I said no you try it
and I went upstairs you [__] suck
dick I was heckling him oh okay so then
um I just left I said take him to my
room
so I went over there my gosh I was about
to drink some tequila and forget about
my sobriety I watched PBS I think Frank
Sinatra your hair just died or they were
playing Frank Sinatra that's live right
that's what people say right you're
riding high in April shot down in me but
I know I'm Gonna Play That Tune when I'm
back on top in June you know it's like
life is up ups and downs yeah
so I have my 900 still so I didn't give
a [__] they pay me right there or not
right
so I came to the airport but I still
haven't got paid for both shows and plus
they open for the flight
I'm talking to the Promoter on the phone
he's in Hawaii and said man I'm waiting
for your wife she doesn't give me the my
money oh she's driving to the airport
right now she's gonna bring it to you
the airport to my hotel room like you
said she was gonna do it last night so I
went into the airport
I'm by the I'm really close to the gate
I have like 25 minutes before they start
boarding
and I'm thinking should I miss my flight
or wait for my money
so
I say [__] this so I went got my flight
and I never got and I called him up I
imagine you never showed up a flight oh
man she was waiting for you
but um and then I told my friend the guy
who booked me hey man your friend never
paid me oh man he did that [__] again
oh
what kind of friend books you on a one
Dexter by the way oh okay he quit comedy
I do have his exact laughs
[Music]
hot breath